نحن نواصل هذه التغطيه اذا الاقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات الاقصى
واعتدائها على المصلين قبل انتهاء صلاه
التراويح هذه صور تاتينا مباشره طبعا هذا
كله حدث قبل قليل الاعداد كانت كبيره داخل
المسجد مراسل الجزيره افاد بملاحقه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المصلين والاعتداء
عليهم داخل المسجد الاقصى وخارجه كما
شاهدنا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعتدت
على الفلسطينيين داخل الاقساط الرصاص
المطاطي ودفعت بمزيد من التعزيزات الى
البلده القديمه في القدس
ومراسلنا هناك الياس كرام افاد بان قوات
الاحتلال منعت سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول
الى باب الاسباط في القدس هذه الصور قبل
قليل وصلتنا لما حدث داخل المسجد الاقصى
على كل حال الياس ما زال معنا الياس لعلك
تجمل لنا ما حدث تبدو صوره مختلفه الان
ربما الاعداد اقل ولكن ما حدث بدا
بالاقتحام حتى قبل ان تنتهي صلاه التراويح
الركعه الاخيره من صلاه التراويح عثمان
كان جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد اقتحموا
باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك باعداد كبيره
مدججين
وبهاراواتهم
وقمعوا الفلسطينيين حقيقه انهم كانوا
يحاولون منع لاي اعتكاف جديد في داخل
المسجد القبلي لكن الموقف تدهور سريعا الى
مواجهه ما بين
الاف الفلسطينيين حقيقه الذين جاؤوا الى
المسجد الاقصى المبارك واعمروه هذا الليل
هذه الليله بالصلوات والتعبد واداء صلاه
التراويح في شهر رمضان المبارك عمليه كر
وفر ومطارده وقمع وضرب الهره واستخدام
السلاح المطاطي الرصاص المطاطي قمع
الفلسطينيين وافراغ باحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك بالكامل من اي مصلل هذا والهدف
المبيض والمخطط له من جانب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كما يبدو هذه الليله لافراغ
المسجد الاقص
تمهيدا لاقتحامات جديده قد تكون على نطاق
اوسع صباحا الخميس في داخل المسجد الاقصى
المبارك من جانبي المستوطنين وكنت تشير
عثمان الى ان اعداد المقتحمين للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك من جانب هؤلاء المتطرفين
تزداد في المناسبات الدينيه وبالمناسبات
الوطنيه وحقيقه الارقام الموجوده بحوزتنا
من جهات يهوديه وجهات اسرائيليه تشير الى
ان الاعداد تزداد وترتفع في عام 2016
عثمان كان عدد المقتحمين طيله السنه 14
الفا ازداد في العام 2017 اي بعد عام الى
25 في العام ثمانيه عشر 29,000 في العام
19 30,000 وفي العام 2020 بسبب الكورونا
انخفض العدد الى 17 تقريبا لكنه عاد
ليرتفع بشكل هائل في العام
2021 الى اكثر من
33 الف مقتحم لباحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وهذه ارقام من مصادر اسرائيليه
ولكن
الاقتحام للمسجد الاقصى المبارك دعنا نشرح
حتى يعني تكون الصوره جليه الان ما حدث هو
ليس انما يوصف بالمتطرفين انهم اقتحموا
ولكن هذه القوات الاسرائيليه المدججه
بالسلاح الرسميه هي التي قامت بالاقتحام
اليس كذلك وبدون بدون اي سبب
بالفعل بدون اي سبب ان نستطيع ان نقول
عثمان بان الاجواء كانت اجواء رائعه اجواء
من التعبد والصلاه والاعتكاف ويعني اجواء
جميله اجواء احتفاليه في احدى ليالي رمضان
صحيح البارده لكن ان هذا لا يمنع عشرات
الاف الفلسطينيين من المجيء واعمار المسجد
الاقصى المبارك واعمار باحاته ومساطبه
ومساجده في داخل الباحات والامور كانت
تسير بكل ثلاثه وبكل حاله من الفرح في في
اوساط كل من جاؤوا الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك للصلاه فيه واداء صلاه التراويح
واذ بقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على حين
الغره وبشكل مكثف تقتحم الباحات وتقمع
المصلين نشير عثمان الى ان هنالك اعداد
كبيره من الفلسطينيين ممن ياتون من قرى
وبلدات فلسطينيه بعيده في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وكذلك ايضا القرى عربيه فلسطينيه
بعيده في داخل الخط الاخضر هم ياتون
المسجد الاقصى المبارك في هذه الليالي
المباركه ويؤدون الصلوات منذ ساعات الصباح
ويفطرون في باحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك
ويتابعون بعد ذلك الى صلاه العشاء وصلاه
التراويح ومنهم من يحب وهذه عاده لدى
البعض ان يعتكف في داخل المسجد القبلي
يقرا القران حتى بزوغ الفجر
ويتعبد لينتظر يوما اخر من الصيام
والامساك لكن عمليا الجيش الاسرائيلي قوات
الاسرائيلي لا تريد لهؤلاء ان يبقوا في
داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك وان يبيتوا في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وان يعتكفوا في
داخله
لانها تريد بالفعل ان تكون هذه الباحات
خاليه وجاهزه لصباح يوم الغد حيث يتوقع ان
تكون الاقتحامات على اشدها من جانب
المستوطنين والمتطرفين مع بني احتفالاتهم
باليوم الاول للفصح اليهودي الذي سوف يمتد
عثمان
الا اسبوع كامل اي الى يوم الاربعاء
المقبل وهذه ايام باستثناء ايام الجمعه
والسبت ستكون على موعد مع عمليات اقتحام
جديده وعمليات ربما قمع من جانب
الاسرائيلي الى الذهن السؤال والسؤال هو
لماذا يقوم الاسرائيليون بما يقومون به ما
هو هدفهم
واضح عثمان بان الهدف هو هدف سياسي هذه
الحكومه الصحيفه ان هي حكومه توصف بانها
الاكثر تطرفا والاشد تطرفا في تاريخ
اسرائيل لكنها لا تختلف حقيقه في التعامل
مع المسجد الاقصى المبارك مع حكومات
اسرائيليه سابقه حتى كانت حكومات محسوبه
على اليسار او على وسط الخريطه الحزبيه في
اسرائيل لكن هذه الحكومه الاشد التطرفا
والتي تشمل في طياتها اشد المتطرفين
الاصوليين والمتشددين دينيا في داخل
اسرائيل هم يريدون ان يثبتوا امرا واحدا
ان القدس بشقيها الغربي
والشرقي هي عاصمه ابديه وموحده لدوله
اسرائيل وان السياده الكامله على الاماكن
المقدسه وتحديدا على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك الذي يسمى عندهم بجبل الهيكل هي
سياده اسرائيليه خالصه شراكه فيها
الرساله الواضحه وعندما يقف على راسي
المكان هناك وسوف نعود اليك بين حين واخ